yes well i'm sean parnell i am not a
politician i like to consider myself a
leader i
i i led in infantry platoon at the
height of the hunt for bin laden back in
2006.
uh our mission was just to find him we
didn't
you know i found a lot of bad guys
instead my platoon took an 85 percent
casualty rate some of my men were
wounded twice i was wounded myself
uh and i was medically retired before my
time i intended to join the military to
make a career of it go into the special
forces
try out for delta i mean that was at
least as a young kid that was my goal
um i didn't get that opportunity i got
blown up by a rocket propelled grenade
and and was put out of the military
medically retired and
and 10 years ago i i left the military
really
broke and broken like didn't really know
what i was going to do with my life in
fact i
came driving back from fort drum which
is where i was stationed you know where
fort drum is
no you said you were looking at upstate
new york so i thought you might uh
so there's two seasons up there july and
winter it's like up on the border with
like it's like up on the border with
canada
yeah and um driving home from there i'm
like i have no idea what i'm gonna do
with my life and so
uh came back to pittsburgh which is
where i was born and raised um
and started i went to grad school came
back with the grad school and
and started trying to tell the story of
my troops because by and large like most
of my soldiers felt like they were
completely forgotten in afghanistan in
fact
they'd go home when their r r leave
their rest and relaxation leave
and and americans would see them in
their uniform and they'd thank them for
their service and they say wow where are
you stationed
oh you were in afghanistan oh thank god
thank god you're in afghanistan because
iraq is just so dangerous and my guys
would be like
what the hell i just got shot in the
head last week wha what
so they'd come back to the battlefield
to the front and talk to me and say sir
they don't know american people don't
know what's going on over here and so
when i was medically retired we all sort
of went our separate ways some
left the army some moved to different
duty assignments and i went back to grad
school and i said you know i have to
figure out a way
to tell their story to make sure that
they had a legacy
you know to make sure that their their
sacrifice was not forgotten so that they
never found themselves in a situation
with their kids or their wife someday
where they may maybe they their
own family didn't know what they had
been through for this country
and so that that the you know that story
uh became out while platoon and outlaw
platoon became a bestseller and that
gave me an opportunity to give back to
my country in greater ways i've been
doing charity
work um you know i've got a a non-profit
that i'm a small part of that gives
service dogs to vets first responders
and their families yeah and so i feel
like
you know you don't need a uniform rank
or a title to serve your community
and so i've been doing that for for
boy eight years now and then
all that changed when the president came
to the district and name dropped me
so so so yeah yeah yeah why did trump
came to your district why did he name
drop you
yeah so i i i've never at that time
i had never talked to him and i still
never met the man
um he came to the district gave a big
speech at the marcellus shale coalition
there
and he sort of name-dropped me to run
for congress and i was like
i wasn't even there i was down in south
carolina at a charity event and i walk
off the stage you know have you ever
like phones just like this like yeah
notifications non-stop just blowing up
i'm like what the hell is going on
and i look at him my mom's just like
ding ding
ding i'm like damn there there's like a
there must be a death in the family i
was afraid
my mom is a very strong italian woman
and she doesn't
she didn't there's like no drama with
her you know what i mean you shouldn't
do that stuff
unless something big is going on and so
i i
find a place to hide and i call her
after this event and they're like public
events so there's like a stage and
people and there's a move that bus
moment with the service dog it's real
cool
and um i'm like mom what what's going on
like
and she goes sean i'm like oh shh
something wrong
i'm like ma what's wrong and she goes
are you running for congress
and i said ma no i'm not running for
congress
and she goes there was just silence and
then she goes
well the president of the united states
says you're running for congress and i
said
ma put put the wine down
it's like too early for this yeah and so
she
gets she sends me this video and you
could probably find the damn thing on
one of these
star trek computers that you got here oh
yeah and and um
and it's the president calling me out
like to run and so i said okay
let's do this turned our life turned my
private sector life upside down
uh got in the race and declared a couple
weeks later and we've been doing this
ever since
and i feel like it's you know running
for political office is a grind in so
many ways but
really you know one of the things i'm a
noob at this you know
but you know politicians tend to think
elections are about them
right yeah but it ain't true elections
are about the people
and so i try to keep my focus on the
people
everyone not just i mean i'm a
republican i'm a conservative
um you and i are probably very different
in a lot of ways yeah but
um i tr i'm a leader like when i was in
afghanistan
i had democrats and republicans in the
same foxhole black
next to white rich next to poor
northerners next to southerners
christians next to atheists and we were
placed on some remote hilltop in
afghanistan and told to figure it out
and i learned very quickly that if that
if we did not learn to look past our
many differences as americans
we would probably perish on some remote
hilltop in afghanistan somewhere
and and so that's sort of become the
bedrock of my leadership philosophy it's
just trying to bring people together
regardless of what they what they
believe or what they look like or what
god they worship
uh because i know that when americans
are united we
really can accomplish anything i mean
for god's sake
we went to the moon with less technology
than you got in this room here yeah you
know
that's actually true your cell phone
exactly more computing power than that
rocket
exactly but we figured it out right
definitely and so united
you know with a free exchange of ideas
you know meeting in the middle coming to
consensus challenging each other
this country can do you can do anything
in fact that's why this country
is where we are today so you're running
against
uh a democrat yes what's his his name is
conor lamb conor lamb
and you're actually in a republican
district yeah right yes it's a
so four years ago if the district had
existed it's a new district it was
gerrymandered so
it it was i don't know what the stats
were it was like an r
plus 20 district where he won his first
race in a special election
it was the only game in town a couple
years later it was drawn to like an r
plus four
maybe an r plus three r plus four so
it's it's more competitive
it's a swing district in every in every
sense of the word it's really the the
district is the quintessential swing
district divided right down the middle
um and he's you know it's a district
that president trump had it existed
four years ago he would have won the
district by oh boy 10 000
or so votes and senator pat toomey who
was also on the ballot that year
a very very different republican from
president trump
also won the district by a larger margin
so two very different republicans have
demonstrated the ability to carry the
district in the last four years
and there's a democrat in there now
right and he's on defense
so for those are just tuning in um it's
particularly convenient that you were
able to come by
for several reasons you just did this
this explosive rnc speech
i thought it was awesome oh thanks man
you all you also uh
i saw the ad you did where you talked
about anti-fun the violence in the far
left
and i have i'm not seeing a lot of that
it often feels like republicans aren't
paying attention
how long has the censorship issue been a
big issue a big problem for a lot of
people online
and we ended up only seeing a couple
republicans actually tackle it
not that i think every single republican
should but there's a handful of people i
can name this ted cruz josh hawley matt
gates who have been focused on issues
that people have been
at least what i'm seeing i don't you
know think that literally everybody sees
the same problems
but particularly particularly online
people who are watching these videos are
seeing antifa writers go around smashing
stuff
and it feels like for one the democrats
are lying about it they're saying it's a
myth
nothing's going on peaceful protest
nothing but peaceful protests they're
just peaceful
and so now we we so i actually uh i hit
you up
recently saying like yo would you would
you be able to come out come on the show
and then several days later when you
know kenosha lit up
and so now we have this this next night
and the you know the lead story that
we're
that we're gonna start with these guys
are showing up to protect businesses so
we'll talk a bit about this
but for those are just tuning in make
sure you hit the like button
uh hit the subscribe button we're live
every monday through friday at 8pm and
that's the general introduction for sean
but let's just uh let's just jump right
into it
what what uh i mean what are your
thoughts on all the riots you made this
powerful ad you had two
really powerful ads actually yeah that
one viral ad where you're walking
through like it's like a warehouse or
yeah you want the full story on that do
that go for it that's wrong
you want to know how it went down well
actually actually let's let's let's
we'll start with the
antifa stuff just because i promised you
know i'm like hey we're going to talk
about it oh we're leading in with it
yeah let's do it okay then
we'll talk about the other ad you did
yeah the second ad i did was an ad that
was condemning the mob violence and
and the thesis or the point of the ad
was that if you don't condemn the mob
uh you you support it you know you've
got to
if we've been told silence is violence
right so or silence is consent
or silence is consent whatever the new
phrase is but
um the point is is i feel like
that the looting the writing the burning
you know
we talked about this what happened to
george floyd was was horrible
absolutely it should not happen in this
country
you know in fact i came out before my
democrat opponent and said
we need we need to seek justice for that
this isn't right uh
and democrats and republicans were
remarkably unified
in that every police officer that i
talked to was like whoa
this ain't right okay so we had this
unprecedented
moment of unity that could have been
seized upon
to to to really to really seek justice
for that family and do
what was right instead
we the writing and looting what it what
it does is
you know it doesn't it doesn't serve
george floyd's memory well
right i think all of us can honestly say
that that these these writing and the
looting is not about george floyd
anymore right
absolutely not and so what's happening
is they're burning down people's
homes their businesses they're
some of these their businesses i mean my
goodness you start you start your own
podcast
how many how much of your blood sweat
and tears did you put into this man it's
starting your own business podcast
venture in this country is not easy to
do any business to be honest
any business most businesses fail and so
when i see innocent people whose
businesses and homes
in and american dreams are being burned
to the ground it upsets me it hurts my
soul
and you know the tragic irony of a lot
of this
is is most of these riots i mean they're
happening in democrat-run cities
they just are it's just a fact um and
they're disproportionately affecting
minority communities
absolutely and minority business owners
there's a
viral tweet going around right now that
shows the the increase in shooting
violence
in new york following defunding the
police and
guess which demographic is predominantly
victimized
in the shootings it's the black
community so in the black community if
you if you look at the polling they want
more police
yeah they want a stronger police
presence and so
all i did with the ad was just say
if you don't condemn the mob you endorse
the mob there's a call to action a shot
across the bow for both political
parties to say look
look this is this is our history right
and
you know here's here's the way i explain
it to people on the stump in pittsburgh
right
while democrats and republicans on the
hill quibble about who's worse
you know teddy roosevelt or grant or
christopher columbus or saint michael
and what statue should you know yeah the
the these
the antifa right and these these
self-proclaimed
marxists these trained marxists and this
isn't just me saying this is on their
website
they've said it themselves so if we just
said in the city of pittsburgh
all the 70s super bowls the four super
bowls that the steelers won
they didn't happen and you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna take all
those super bowl trophies out of heinz
field
all the players that made it into the
hall of fame during the 70s
taking them out all the blood sweat and
tears that the fans the coaching staff
and the players invested
in those super bowls didn't happen well
everybody that grew up in the city of
pittsburgh cheering for the steelers
would still love the steelers do you
want to know why
because it's woven into the fabric of
our dna we love the steelers we wear our
jerseys to church on
sunday for god's sake so we would still
love the steelers but you know what my
kids the next generation
a little bit less the generation after
that
probably not at all and so oh you know
the washington football team i got i got
some uh
redskins ziploc bags i i had to make
sure i could buy something off amazon
because they were getting rid of it
and i don't like censorship i don't like
destruction of history
i like preserving art and so i went on
amazon and i bought
a box of redskins ziploc bags you can't
buy them on amazon anymore
are you sponsored by ziploc is that why
you're doing that no i thought it was
kind of funny like of all the things i
could get i got
ziploc bags it's hilarious i could
actually use them well so the point is
is that this is this is about making
america easier to change generations
from now
okay they're playing the long game and i
cut that ad to help
wake people up and you know i i had
you know people in the media you know in
in local pittsburgh papers saying that
you know oh
you know sean you can do better than
that the rhetoric i'm like
so wait a second you're not okay
with me calling out mob violence but
you're okay with the mob violence
right like it's not okay for me to
condemn it but it's okay it
you know it's okay to burn people's
buildings down and you're going to
condemn
me for calling it out but not my
opponent
who is posing in with defund the police
stuff did he really pose and defund the
police yes wow
oh man yes that's crazy because every
ever
he'll he'll tell you well of course i'm
not for defunding the police it's like
yeah okay
okay well i mean you're marching around
with protesters
posing with pictures arm and arm would
defund the police signs
now imagine i did something like that
with me saying well i don't really
believe that would
that ever fly no they did it with uh the
dude we had on the other day billy
prempe he's a republican running in
north jersey
he took a picture of a bunch of people
one guy pulled out a q flag all of a
sudden they're wrong
yeah that's exactly right that's a great
that's a great example that's a great ex
you know and i mean it would it's not
it wouldn't be excusable for me so you
know you know so
i wish it was i i i'd have no problem
saying look the guy's probably marching
around
some people pull out a defund the police
thing i'm gonna ask him about if he
denies it that's okay
same one go for you but the media won't
give you that courtesy no they won't
the media is only one side gets a
courtesy it's it's beyond courtesy
it is oh they're fully overt the main
campaigning the mainstream the main
such such an overused term but the
mainstream media they they really are
they really are in the tank
look i i i used to hear
the president talk about fake news and i
used to laugh right
and i'm like yeah it's true but you know
this president being tongue in cheek
he's funny
right and and the president he likes to
get people riled up you know he just
does he's a fighter like that
and um that's uh incidentally i like
that
i like that about him i like that he's a
fighter and i think that's why people
elected him because they feel like he's
a fighter
um and i'll give you my logic on that if
you get in a couple minutes but
um you know i i don't even remember
where the hell i was going with that
fake news trump's a phone oh yeah there
you go there you go yeah well so
so now but now that i'm in a race i'm
like
oh my god fake news it's everything it's
everywhere yeah and so
i'm i'm i'm half joking but i'm half not
but if you look you look at some of the
headlines out there today
they clearly don't want the president to
be reelected oh certainly and the new
york times
i think it was this morning peaceful
marches give way
turn violent turn it's like no no they
even say turn violent say give way
to burning buildings and looting or to
like fires and looting it's like
give way that's what is your at some
serious mental illness
yeah so i pulled up a bunch of these
stories protest protest protest protest
they all say protest they'll say
demonstration they'll
a bunch of them say peaceful and it's
like uh what you're saying
you know how they want to make it easier
to change this country i think
what we're seeing with the media is
there's two things for the most part
they're scared of the left i think most
of these big companies that bend the
knee
to the the woke out rage are scared of
violence like you got this video
where you know i don't think i can play
it but you got this video
where they surround this woman uh she's
leaning back as they're screaming in her
face demanding she raise her fist
yeah this image to me is the perfect
example of what's been happening across
this country for all these companies
for all these politicians for the media
if if i'll put it this way
if you said hey we should fund the
police
and they said no way would you rally a
bunch of people to go and smash windows
and start fires
absolutely not exactly i mean look this
this is why
there's this poll that came out recently
something like
67 percent and don't don't quote me on
the numbers i'm i'm
67 percent of americans some huge number
don't feel comfortable sharing their
political views yeah cato institute yeah
in fact the only people that do feel
comfortable
are like the far left far left and so
that that's why
you know when we i see it play out on
the ground in in politics while we
campaign like we work really hard to go
everywhere and meet people and build
coalitions and be there for the people
and you know we'll go to people's doors
and be like hey do you want do you want
to sign because that's part of like the
gig you're like hey you want to sign
you're like yeah we'll take one of your
signs that's great what do you want to
assign for the president oh no we don't
want our house to get burned down yeah
yeah
i mean but is that not a sad commentary
of where we are
that was the so we talk about my my
speech at the convention that was part
of it like yeah
let's like the republican party we are
the big tent party
we're the party of diversity of thought
in our tent you will be free
in our tents you will not be canceled in
our tents you are free
and so i feel like we want to cultivate
that in america but that's part of what
made america such an exceptional country
so let's uh so obviously you wouldn't
lead a march with torches but
obviously the left would right when they
are so think about it
look at this look at this video right
this video is scary
this video is scary horrifying
surrounding this woman she's being
pushed back and they're screaming at her
raise your fist she's saying no
there's this this is not the only video
they went around to a bunch of
restaurants
but so so think about what that means
you work for you know cnn they smashed
up the front of cnn building
and they they tried breaking the lobby i
think they got in they got shoved out
they've gone to other companies they
will threaten violence
and it works it works these companies
bend the knee as fast they can
and so what ends up happening going back
to what the point i was making about
these these companies uh
these news outlets that say protesters
instead of rioters
one one big reason is that they're
scared they'll be attacked
they go on the ground they do get
attacked true we we had this uh
uh elijah schaefer as a reporter for the
blaze do you see his video that came out
where the guy flipped the gun in his
face
you hear a click i don't know if he
actually drive-fired ex-doesn't look
like his fingers on the trigger but
there's a there's a click
elijah's saying he's he's they're
they're in the middle of a conversation
what do you do
you know what would you do the cops and
the guy pulls out a gun and points it at
him and then puts it away
and it sounds like you know there's a
click of some sort i don't know what it
is but
they're willing to get violent and
they're willing to target journalists
so a lot of these journalists are scared
and would say hey
i would rather not challenge them yeah
you know because i don't want to have
any violence directed at me
but i think the more nefarious thing
that needs to be brought up is that
these journalists
many of them write peaceful marches
because they're on their side
and they're covering for them on purpose
and i know because i've worked at these
companies
and they straight up are like no no no
no you know don't say it like that
because it'll make them look bad
believe me i mean you know if look i
mean you talked about you
not a single i don't want to say not a
single most democrats would never win
elections if the media didn't constantly
fly cover for them
you know most people in my district do
not know
about conor lamb's radical voting record
okay and look i'm
i'm sure that he's a nice guy right uh
i'm campaigning on his record on his
policy votes he's making it personal
making up lies about me and stuff like
that but that's what they do when
they're losing that's what the left does
this character assassination the
politics of personal destruction
that's why i didn't that's why i was
loath about getting into politics in the
first place
right but if we lo if we allow the left
to do that
then good people don't rise up and run
out of fear we can't allow it to happen
so i felt that this country was
important enough and
the future the gen the next generation
for my children we want to make sure
that our kids
all of our kids inherit a country that
is rich with opportunity and it's just
as vibrant as the one that you and i
i want my kids to have the same
opportunity that you did if not more
that's our job that's what my parents
thought so my grandparents thought
and it was hard fought and in what and
so
if if the media were playing fair
you know democrats would likely never
win because their agenda in this day and
age and i say democrats i really am
drawing a distinction
new democrats okay you know old you know
the union democrats that built this
country that really
they really did built this country from
the ground up are not the same
people as alexander ocasio-cortez i'm
you know and i'm not trying to i'm not
trying to impugn her either i'm just
simply saying
that my grandfather was a lifelong union
democrat and he would not recognize the
democrat party today in fact
most democrats that i talked to cannot
believe
the democrat party platform in 2020
and and they're looking for other
options and i think as as a leader
you know yeah i'm a republican and i'm a
conservative and i don't shy away from
that but i consider myself a leader
and a representative of the people first
last and always and leaders we've got to
step up and give those people an option
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode